(Man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance to secure
an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
First there's the innovators,
then there's the imitators,
then there's the idiots.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money,
and they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Nobody builds a more well-run
sales network than I do.
Oh, that is absolute crap.
Mike. Mike.
No, that is so True.
Mike. Oh, come on.
You've got a great plan.
You gotta execute.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
All we want to know is,
hey, will chicks dig it?
It's sink...
This is not morality tank.
Or swim.
We've sold $2 million.
Wow!
Whoa!
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew
his homegrown clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
First into the shark tank are
Sarah Ponn and Mike Hartwick,
who believe they're on the cusp
of the next big fitness craze.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Mike Hartwick...
and I'm Sarah Ponn...
and we're here to present
our company surfset fitness.
We are seeking $150,000
for 10% equity in our company.
Surfset fitness is surf-inspired
exercise equipment
and group fitness classes.
This is the ripsurferx.
It's the world's
first total body surf trainer.
We've designed it to mimic
the instability
of a surfboard on water.
And we have here with us
Lakey Peterson.
She's one of the top ten
female surfers in the world
and she's here to show you
a few of her moves.
So Lakey's gonna walk through
the pop-up.
This is one of our moves
in surfset.
It's extremely challenging.
It's an athletic move.
She's gonna use her arms,
her core,
balance, stability.
You can see she's rocking
side to side...
cool.
All about the imbalance.
Now she's gonna show you
how a surfer
would dive under a wave.
This is called a duck dive.
You can see she's engaging
her triceps, her chest,
really working the arms,
the core.
And we're gonna finish with
what we call a water Walker.
So it's similar
to a one-Legged squat.
You can see that she's trembling
a little bit.
She's engaging every muscle
in her core, her legs.
So we're here today, sharks,
because we have
more interest and orders
than we can handle
and we need your help.
That looks like it's very hard
for the average person to do
any of those exercises.
That's quite complex. It's very
difficult to stay stabilized.
Let's take an average bozo
like Robert.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Come on up.
The only thing I ask is
your shoes off.
Get the full experience,
if you can.
She made it look pretty easy.
It didn't look that hard,
I gotta be honest.
So she's had some experience.
So we get up one foot at a time.
All right, I'll step on.
There you go.
And then bend the knees.
Get into your carve and your
surfing motion. Look at him.
Whoa! Nicely done!
(Mark) Easy, rob.
Whoo!
What was the really hard move?
Was--was the one foot?
The one foot.
(Mark) The one leg.
(Daymond) Single foot.
You go one leg
and then you just go like that,
as if you're, like, stroking
through the water with your...
ooh. That's a little Harder.
Whoa.
(Sarah) like skateboarding,
kind of.
(Mike) So, yeah, you gotta find
that middle.
(Lakey) It's a little, uh,
it's a little shaky on that one.
(Mark) Good night, Robert.
(Robert) That was good. Thanks.
How do you change
the--the levels?
You can change it
really quickly.
Change it on the fly. So...
So you want to make this hard?
Snap these off.
And it goes just like that.
That makes it harder.
You can take all three off.
And are those on both sides?
Yes.
What happens if you weigh
300 pounds?
Can you still use it?
450.
The board's weight-tested.
Boy, I gotta tell you
I'm a little tired.
See? Yeah.
How'd you come up
with the idea?
This guy will tell you.
So I was, uh, I was
a professional hockey player,
and I've been
a lifelong surfer.
As I was getting towards
the end of my career,
I decided, you know, I want
to surf a little bit more,
and every time that I spent
more time in the ocean,
I was--I felt better
on my skates,
I-I performed better,
I had better seasons.
I really found right then
that there is a tie
between fitness and surfing.
We made $150,000 in 4 months
running classes.
So we took it to new York,
our 11 machines.
We set up in a--
a very large gym there.
Believe it or not, it just--
Media windfall.
"Good morning America."
We had celebrities on the board,
"Access Hollywood."
We had people paying
$35 a class.
We sold out classes
for the entire four months.
I'm getting more interested.
How much is this unit
retailing for?
$400.
And your cost?
$150.
You're gonna have to get this
down to $100
for it to retail at $400.
Uh, it's not a problem.
Who's running the show here
on the business side?
That's a good question.
(chuckles) So, um,
when I went to europe,
I got my M.B.A.
I tried it in finance
for a little bit.
You tried finance, you said?
Yeah. Was in finance.
So do you think that
there's anything odd about
valuing this company
at $1.5 million?
Um, no.
We've also had 200 inquiries
for franchising,
to open private studios.
So you're coming here
for not only our money
but our strategic assistance,
but you're only offering us 10%.
Why would you offer us
so little?
It might be a little
right now,
but that 10%
of a large company is--
But a company
that we have to work for.
We don't want you guys
to work for us.
We want to work for--for you.
In a sense, we want you to be
able to make a phone call
and we want to show up
and do what we do.
How much do you think
those phone calls cost?
A lot, but we don't want--
It took me 20 years
of kissing a lot of butt
to get some of those people...
right. Exactly.
On my rolodex.
That's why we value it
so highly.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Because I think that
it's a great idea,. you could
actually go out there
and hire professional surfers to
be your certifiers and trainers,
which would give you
a lot of authentication.
Because of that,
I think you're gonna need more
than $150,000 in cash
to do it right.
And in order to make
an investment in this,
I have to have enough skin
in the game.
So what I'm gonna do is
offer you $300,000
for 33%.
So listen,
what just happened there
is he knocked the value down
from a million and a half
to $900,000.
But I put you in position
to get out there
and not have to stress about how
much cash you have for inventory
and to not stress about hearing
these guys nickel-and-dime you.
You got nickeled-and-dimed
for 33% just now.
(Robert) It's
an interesting offer, Mike.
I see the business
a little bit differently.
I think you don't need
the professional surfer guys.
I think they're great,
but I think that can be
intimidating to a lot of people.
The trainers need to be bubbly,
energetic.
I'll give you the $150,000--
'cause I don't think you should
give up that much equity.
It's gonna go big--for 20%.
So a lower valuation is
basically what you're saying.
I'm saying keep more equity.
Nobody starts a company
out of their basement
and works their butt off
to give up one-Third of it
at this stage.
Don't gamble your future
until you know what you have.
A lower valuation
for less money.
Funny. Every time
I say something,
I hear somebody else talking.
That always happens to you,
Robert.
It's like a shadow.
That always happens to you,
Robert.
It's like a mini-me.
I have a--an offer as well.
And I own many, uh,
crossfit gyms, so I understand
the lifestyle and the culture.
I'm willing to give $150,000,
but unlimited manufacturing
of the boards.
25%.
For free? You're giving
the boards for free?
(Robert laughs)
And I just give you
the cash, right?
So you--You have--
You're a finance guy.
That's why
I'm not messing around.
All the options available
to you.
Yeah, but when you go through
that cash,
you still have to put it back
in. You have to put it back in.
I'm giving you cash,
and then I'll manufacture
the boards.
Sarah, Mike,
what are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
All five sharks are still in,
and Sarah and Mike have
three offers on the table.
Keep an eye on one thing here
as these offers come in,
because it matters.
You started with $1.5 million
as for the value
of what you created here.
Mark knocked you down 33%
to $900,000.
These two very greedy sharks
have knocked you down to half
of what you asked for.
But also manufacturing is--
is a plus. That's--That's--
factoring. He's--
It's just factoring, Mike.
You're gonna have
the money anyway.
(Daymond) It's not just
factoring. It's not at all.
You're gonna wanna do apparel.
You're gonna want
to do board shorts.
You're gonna want to do
a bunch of things.
No, you're not.
We just--
They're already selling
a lifestyle, Robert.
No, no,
but not at the beginning.
The way they're gonna fail is by
doing too many things at once.
They don't know that.
But they don't need to do
too many things at once
if they have me on that side.
(Kevin) You know what?
I like Daymond's better.
I like the apparel thing.
I think I want a piece
of your deal.
(Barbara) I want
to stop you right there.
(Kevin) I like it better
than Mark's.
(Barbara) I just want
to give you a word of caution.
The best guy for you
on this deal is Mark Cuban.
Smart lady.
What? That's ridiculous. Why?
You're honest,
you say it like it is,
and you want to know something?
And you're crazy.
No. You just be quiet, please.
Mark's that way.
He's much richer than you,
but he's cut out
of the same cloth. Right.
Now what I'm going
to offer you is
to take half of mark's position.
(speaks indistinctly)
There you go.
Wait! No. No. No.
Barbara, why don't you suck up
to everybody?
No. No.
And it's totally up to mark.
The reason you should listen is
nobody builds
a faster, more well-run
sales network than I do.
I know that--
Oh, that is absolute crap.
Mike--
No, that is so true.
Mike. Oh, come on.
(Robert) Mike, I started
a company nine years ago...
(Barbara) So True.
3 guys. We're 160 people today
and $100 million in sales.
We did $52 million last quarter.
This is what this is.
You've got a great plan.
You gotta execute.
I rolled about six crossfit gyms
in the last four months
as well
as a big training program.
And if you know anything
about crossfit,
it's very hard
to get certified.
Yes, but he's a short man...
(laughs)
And that doesn't figure image
at all.
(mark laughs) Wow, Barbara.
So, Mark, are you in
or are you out with Barbara?
Sorry, Barbara.
I don't need you on this one.
I'm going alone.
Okay. In that case, I'm out.
Do you want more money
than $150,000 today?
I think that we could--
that we could benefit
from more money right now.
If we had more,
we could do it faster.
If you have
a manufacturing pipeline,
you don't need more money.
When a business is
on the fast track,
one of the biggest challenges
they have
is to keep up
with success,
because they don't have
enough cash available to them
to meet demand,
and then somebody else steps in
to meet that demand.
And the quicker you get
to the point you need
to preempt those competitors,
the more successful
you're going to be.
Let me throw in here
for a second,
because I'm listening
to all this
and I'm saying to myself,
you're either gonna execute
and make this huge, 'cause I
believe you have that potential,
and brand is a big part of it.
The real lasting value
is not just that device.
It's the brand
you're gonna create.
The number one guy to build
a brand here is this guy.
So I want to tack on
to his deal.
I'll bring you in
on the deal.
Yeah, I'd like to do that.
Because they have to.
Yeah.
And This is where my
24-Second shot clock comes in,
'cause I need a decision.
$300,000 in cash
for a third,
full partner.
Should you need more
because business just explodes,
there's more money there.
I don't think you need
to give up
one-third of your business
today.
I think that would be foolish
and I don't think
you guys are foolish.
That's way too much.
So, Mike, I'm giving you
$150,000 for 20%.
Barbara's out.
Daymond and Kevin are
$150,000 for 25%
and they're giving you...
(Daymond) Manufacturing.
(speaks indistinctly)
Manufacturing.
Mark Cuban is in at $300,000,
but he's stealing one-Third
of your company today.
(whispers) Sarah,
what's your preference?
Go with your feeling.
(normal voice) I mean,
manufacturing and brand
is very important for us
right now.
Sarah, Mike,
what are you gonna do?
Counter 30%.
Huh? Is there any way
to come down on any of that?
You talking to me?
Yeah.
A little bit.
A little bit on the, uh,
ownership?
I'll come down to 30%
if you say "Yes" right now.
No, don't do it.
A designer alone is gonna
cost you $150,000.
Push, Sarah. You know
the right thing to do here.
Mark, we're gonna accept
your offer.
That's what I'm talking about!
(Barbara) Yes! Yes!
Ah! Horrible deal.
(Barbara) Great deal.
(Kevin) Horrible!
Thank you. Congratulations.
We're gonna make a lot of money.
We're gonna make
a lot of money.
You just made yourself
millionaires.
Absolutely.
Yes!
Oh, my god. (laughs
and speaks indistinctly)
You know, mark,
you stole their souls.
That's what you did.
You guys are
so full of crap.
You're a thief.
(speaks indistinctly)
So excited. There were
so many offers coming out.
I'm--I'm confident
we made the right decision
and looking forward
to getting started.
We're so excited.
It's exactly what we wanted.
♪♪♪
In season one,
Jonathan Miller struck a deal
with Kevin Harrington
for his custom energy bar
company element bars.
All right. 30%.
We have a deal.
Okay.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Business has been amazing
since I've been on "Shark Tank."
Sales, which started out
at only a hundred or so per day,
are now thousands.
We went from
a small wedding cake bakery
to our own facility.
We hired ten people to produce
thousands of bars per day.
30% of our business is
actually producing bars
for other bar companies
that sell into
National retail outlets.
And by the end of the year,
we will reach
one million bars sold.
(laughs) Yeah!
One million bars.
We got our first cereal order!
Today's an exciting day
because we are launching
our new product line,
element cereal.
Element cereal is custom cereal.
You pick the ingredients,
we bake it fresh for you,
and then we ship it
to your house.
And out the door.
Here's the first box.
(man) Whoo!
"Shark Tank" was a great
launching pad for our business.
I'm so glad that I accepted
the challenge
and took a dive into the tank
with the sharks.
(all) Element cereal!
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
Aaron Marino,
who believes he can help men
everywhere be more confident.
Hello. I'm Aaron Marino,
owner of Alpha M Consulting,
and I'm here today seeking
a $50,000 investment
for 10% equity stake
in my company.
As men, we're motivated
by two things--Money
and sex--And my company
helps them get more of both.
Whoa.
There were zero resources
out there
for everyday average guys
to get solid, basic advice
on how to look great.
Now sure, there are a handful
of men's fashion magazines,
but this is not reality
for 95% of us dudes out there.
We don't care
what the latest brand
of overpriced designer jeans
are.
All we want to know is
hey, will chicks dig it?
(sharks laugh)
Nobody ever teaches
or encourages us to look good,
and when we do,
we're mocked and ridiculed,
called names
like "metrosexual."
To those people, I say,
"sit back and watch.
"watch as my clients pass you
on the corporate ladder
and get the number of the woman
who just rejected you."
(laughs)
I have developed
a 6-Disc dvd series
that helps a man analyze
and build
the perfect basic wardrobe.
Meet Joe.
(Robert) What a slob.
Joe is average,
but by using
the alpha m style system,
Joe can build
the perfect basic wardrobe,
with a simple-to-follow
fashion formula.
Joe's got a hot date.
He follows the formula,
and Joe transforms
from average Joe...
(chimes tinkle)
(Robert) whoa!
To an alpha male.
I'll take this Joe.
(Robert) Are they twins?
Aaron, can we see
the other guy again?
Can we compare the two?
Yeah. Come on out.
Tell me, if I buy the dvd,
walk me through
how the dvd works.
The foundation of the style
system is the inventory list.
There are 59 essential items.
Each item has a specific number
and letter code.
Each outfit has a formula
that correlates directly
to the inventory list.
Right here.
This will explain it.
Oh, I love your
"a.1 + b.2 + e.1 + g.1" outfit.
That's very simple, by the way.
(Mark and Robert laugh)
Basically, that equation--
You get action.
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
All right,
and what city are you in?
I'm in Atlanta,
but I'm--I'm worldwide.
(laughs)
I'm a regular guy.
I just happen to know more about
manscaping and shoes
than I do football.
(laughs)
And this is the way that I--
manscaping?
This is... (chuckles)
We'll talk.
(Mark) Ha!
Aaron, could you make anybody
better-Looking?
Anybody.
Can you make Kevin
better-looking?
You tell us what you would do
with this guy.
I think I'm very well-dressed
right now.
(Barbara) And be quite honest
with this.
Yeah, he would put a feed bag
on him.
Other than the jacket being
a little bit too tight,
it's not gonna be too much.
No,
I'm 3 pounds overweight.
Aaron, would you recommend
a hairpiece?
No. Oh, no. That's one thing--
the brand.
Don't touch the brand.
No. No. No. No. No.
One thing I would do...
just asking.
I'd probably bring the sideburns
down a little bit,
slightly angle them
to follow the jaw,
and that's just gonna give
a little dimension to his face.
I'd love that.
Eyebrows look good.
Everything looks great. His
shoes are beautifully polished.
I might just give this guy
10 grand for the heck of it.
You're great.
(Kevin) So what happens?
You get this slob guy.
Mm-hmm.
He finds out about Alpha M.
He tries this for how much?
$297.
Ooh.
(Robert) Ooh.
How many have you sold
in the last six months?
I actually just launched it.
I sold 75 in 4 weeks.
$75,000?
75 units.
This year I should project
around $250,000.
First quarter, I did $61,000.
Uh, last month--
Sorry, Aaron. Let's go back.
How can you get to $61,000
in sales for the quarter
when you've only sold 75 cds?
I also--
I sell inter--Services.
50% of my sales are local,
domestic.
So included in your estimate
of sales...
Mm-hmm.
Is you consulting with people,
right?
Yeah. I may be shipping dvds,
but what I sell is confidence.
Aaron.
(speaks indistinctly)
I've been called
a bloodhound up here
'cause I get
to the bottom of things.
Mm-hmm.
So are you looking for us
to give you more than money,
but give you access, help?
I need help.
I need help with technology.
I need help with
international distribution.
And how much help would you like
me to put in on a weekly basis?
(Robert) Full-time job, Daymond.
The real truth is you want us
to work for you.
Um...
yes or no?
As a partner. Partner, yes.
I'm out.
Okay.
I think you have
an interesting business,
and I believe
that you found a niche,
evidenced by the fact you're
taking in over $100,000.
It's not a bad business.
I'm not sure how leverageable
it is.
You are the whole brand,
so, I mean, a scenario that
I would be worried about is,
one day you step out
into the street,
and some guy wearing sandals
and white Socks,
driving a bus, runs you over.
(Daymond laughs)
Kevin, I see my death
as an opportunity.
You put "Style guardian Angel"
on there before...
(sharks laugh)
Hey, I put a white suit on,
some fluffy clouds,
maybe a Harp,
and I'm like,
"yo, alpha's checked out
"to the big wardrobe
in the sky.
I'm still here to be
your style guardian Angel."
I love it.
What's really important,
what we learned today,
is I'm the best-dressed shark,
and I thank you for that.
Oh, I don't think so.
But even with that on the table,
I don't think
it's an investable business.
I'm out.
I think where you're off track
here is the dvd set,
because I can't imagine
you selling that at--
What was your price again?
$297.
It's a ridiculous price.
I think you're going down
the wrong path here.
I'm out.
What--
I'm sorry to cut you off.
What's the price
of a compliment?
I mean, what is the price
of getting a number of a woman?
He's good.
You know what? He is good.
I think
you're a great consultant,
But the dvd--
I just don't see that working.
I don't think the slob guy is
gonna buy a dvd
and on his own, look like that.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
If I were to do this deal,
and someone said to you,
"who's your investor?"
it's Mark Cuban,
and I'm looking like that?
'cause I actually think that's
a better look than that look.
Really?
(Robert laughs)
There's no way you're gonna get
me wearing a tight sweater
and folded-over and a tie.
Right.
That's not gonna happen.
So it's--It's just
not a good fit.
(Robert) Oh, come on.
I appreciate it.
I understand.
So for that reason, I'm out.
Everybody's out?
(Daymond) Yes. Yes.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for your time.
(Robert) Thank you.
You all fantastic.
Come on, guys.
Bye, slob guy.
(Aaron) That's okay.
You win some, you lose some.
I'm still helping guys.
♪♪♪
I'm Becky App...
and I'm Abby Jordan.
And we opened up
an ice cream parlor
in the heart
of Omaha, Nebraska.
It's a very traditional
family-friendly ice cream store.
(doorbell rings)
Hi. Welcome to ecreamery.
Hi. I'm here
to pick up my order.
Oh. Great.
People have a connection
to ice cream.
We like to call it
a super comfort food.
Would you like to try a sample
of cinnamon cheesecake?
It makes you feel better.
It makes you happy.
You cannot have a frown
on your face
when you're eating ice cream.
What would you like to try?
Can I have
the pink peppermint?
Sure.
There's a need for our product
in the marketplace.
We figured out a way to put
a new spin on ice cream.
We're doing something
no one has ever done before.
We've really sacrificed a lot
because we believe
in this business.
We gave up very successful
careers in the corporate world.
It's just us,
literally making each
and every one of these pints.
We can't go on like this
forever.
We're just barely keeping
our heads above water.
We really need the sharks
so we can build this
into the huge
multimillion-dollar business
that we know it can be.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Abby Jordan.
And I'm Becky App.
We're ecreamery ice cream
and gelato...
and we're asking
for $250,000
for 33% equity in our company.
Who doesn't love ice cream?
However, no one
in the $23 billion
ice cream industry
is positioning ice cream
as a gift.
Sharks, the days
of sending flowers are over.
Here's how it works.
Step one--Visit our website,
where you rule the scoop.
Step two--Design your flavor.
Do you want ice cream, gelato,
or sorbetto?
Choose from over 50 flavors.
Even choose your mix-Ins,
from chocolate Fudge brownies
to Bacon.
Step three--Name your flavor.
For instance,
Lilly's feel better bites.
And step four--
We deliver it to your doorstep.
So, sharks, as we propose
our sweet deal,
please enjoy
your own personalized flavor
we've made for you.
We have
Robert's Investmint Mix,
Barbara's Delicious Dividends,
Mr. Wonderful's Shark Bait,
Daymond's
Fashionable Flavor Factory,
and last,
we have the Cubanero...
Thank you, dear.
Dark chocolate habanero
sorbetto.
That sounds like me.
Wow. That is good.
It's a delicious deal, right?
Mmm.
Wow. That's amazing.
That's pretty delicious.
(Barbara) Heavy ice cream.
It's creamy.
(Kevin) Very good.
Mmm.
Okay, ladies,
$750,000 valuation.
Do you have any sales?
We've sold $2 Million since
inception at the end of 2007.
(sharks) Whoa!
Well, what about this year?
We're on track to do $750,000.
Whoa.
And how much money
will you make on that?
$60,000.
Why are the margins so low?
They're not low.
They're 60% margins.
Well, then why?
Where's all the money going?
$750,000 in sales.
You're only making $60,000
on that.
We have spent a significant
amount of money
into building
a very solid infrastructure.
This is a great time
for you guys to be involved.
This is the tipping point.
We have invested
into our machinery,
into tried and True recipes,
the process
of shipping ice cream,
which isn't as easy
as it may seem.
Yeah, Becky, how do you ship it
without it melting?
We ship it in a reusable cooler
on dry ice.
How much does that cost?
We sell a 4-Pint ice cream gift
for an average of $55
on our site.
Plus shipping.
Shipping, right.
So second-Day air is $25.
Who pays for that?
The customer.
The customer pays for it.
So they end up paying
$75 for the gift?
$80.
Yeah.
Yes.
Even as a gift, $80
is very, very expensive
for four pints
of ice cream.
What we like to say is,
the last time you sent flowers,
what did you spend?
But that's exactly the point.
I don't think that's expensive.
'cause every time
I do something wrong
and my wife yells at me,
I'm spending at least
$250 for roses.
We have an all-apologies
pack of ice cream.
Do you make
the ice cream yourselves?
Yes.
Why?
Like we said before,
you can't look at this
as 16 ounces of cream and sugar.
This is a personalized,
heartfelt message.
And I... (laughs)
Maybe I should direct
the conversation.
I know how you feel
about that.
I love the idea.
I mean, I think
if you sell it as ice cream,
it's very expensive.
But if you sell it
as a lifestyle experience,
it's not.
Okay. What are you doing
for customer acquisition,
and what is your cost
for customer acquisition?
We are spending all
of our marketing budget
on online advertising.
What does it cost you
to get a customer?
$20 a customer,
but that customer's
going to repeat purchase.
How many times?
Right now, average customers
are purchasing
about twice a year.
Okay. And my profit
on a customer?
Our margins are 60%.
But let's step back.
You said you were
lifestyle guys?
How did you get
into this business?
With our investor,
we purchased a non-Functioning
ice cream Web site.
We rebuilt it
and repositioned it
as an ice cream gift site.
How much does your investor
own of the company?
70%.
70%?
Oh!
Wow.
Whoa. And how much
did they put in, Abby?
Wow. How much did they put in?
He put in $600,000.
Oh!
Was it Warren Buffet?
He gave you close to
a million-Dollar valuation
from a concept
about ice cream?
He is a venture capitalist.
He is very successful
in--in the e-Commerce space.
He wants one of you guys.
I'm sure.
And you are offering us
33% of the company?
Does this investor--
Is he aware of this?
Yes.
Absolutely.
He's--he's--
It's out of his share?
It's of his share.
We want your capital
and your connections,
'cause we know that we can
take this to the next level.
What do you think
it's gonna take
to get you
to the next level?
We want the capital
for a production facility.
We make and ship
and sell everything
out of our ice cream parlor.
Is there value today
to have a retail,
bricks and mortar presence
and an online presence?
In other words,
if you shut down the retail,
would the online
be more profitable?
Yes, it would.
I'm getting intrigued,
I have to admit.
I'll make you an offer.
Because I also value
promotion--
I don't know which of
the other shark or sharkettes
would be interested,
but I'll give you
$125,000 for 25%.
But the price is $250,000.
I heard that.
Well, he needs
a partner, Barbara.
That's such
a bogus strategy, though.
If you like it...
really?
If you wanna be in,
you can be in.
If not, be quiet.
If you want it--250k.
No.
You know?
Another shark? Come on.
No, because I think
the problem with this deal is,
the cost of customer
acquisition is huge.
They need a massive amount
of promotion.
I think the problem
with the deal is,
they have one of the guys
like us behind them.
I'm not gonna give up
my money and my time
for somebody else who owns
70% of the company.
I'm out.
I love the idea.
But you got online,
you got bricks and mortar,
you got another investor.
There's just too much
going on.
I'm out.
We're ready to focus
on the online.
We know that's
what's going to scale.
So Robert's point--
The best idea here
that I've heard,
is to shut down your store.
I don't really think
you need a partner here.
I think you need
a loan of some kind.
I'm out.
Well, we're
very disappointed.
We were really
looking forward to...
I would love
to have you as partners,
but I would never
get my money out,
and I would start
to hate you.
Whoa. Nasty.
Wow. This is
a tough sale, girls.
I'm throwing a bone out here,
and nobody's biting.
Mark, where are you at?
I think it's
a brilliant idea.
Thank you.
But there's a saying
that I love.
It says, "first,
there's the innovators,
"then there's the imitators,
then there's the idiots."
You're the innovator.
The problem is, you haven't
been imitated yet.
Because it's such
a good idea, you will be.
As you get more successful,
people are going to say,
"you know what?
"I can do this locally.
I don't have
the $25 shipping cost."
For that reason,
I'm out.
(Daymond) You have one shark
left to deal with.
The meanest guy here.
That's the good news.
The bad news is...
it's Kevin.
It's Kevin.
(Mark and Barbara laugh)
Well, all good roads
lead to uncle kev.
(Robert) And he's only
giving you half the money.
The reason I did that
is I figure
this thing is a massive
promotional challenge,
because you're
educating America
that ice cream is a gift.
And by the way,
it's really good.
The best ice cream
I've ever had, bar none.
Yeah. It is fantastic.
We're--We're going
to make this
a $5 million business
just in the next 3 years.
Ladies, I have bad news.
Please--Please reconsider
matching the offer
so we can build
a production facility.
But because of the greed
of these other sharks...
(laughter)
I'm stuck.
I can't do anything.
So what are you gonna do?
I'm out.
Thank you for tasting it,
for trying it, for loving it.
Good luck.
Terrific job.
Thank you.
The sharks loved
our ice cream.
They're crazy for not taking
this sweet deal,
and we're even more motivated
to make ecreamery
a household name
across America.
♪♪♪
Next up is Neil Desai,
who believes his product
can help save relationships.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Neil Desai,
and I'm the owner
of Cate app.
I'm seeking $50,000
for a 5% equity stake
in my company.
Now whether or not
we like it,
we all know someone
who's been cheated on,
been accused of cheating,
or who's actually cheated.
(laughs)
Let me show you
a situation
that happens to millions
of people every day.
(cell phone vibrates)
Who is that?
(laughs)
Oh, it's nobody.
What is this?!
Jenny? Jenny
from your work?
Yeah. I mean--
What is this?
Are you cheating on me?
No! I'm not--
You liar!
(smacks)
Ah!
(sharks laugh)
Have you been there,
Kevin?
Whoa!
Tell--Tell me more.
Well, Cate helps prevent
fights like this
simply by Keeping
your indiscretions discreet.
Quite simply, Cate is
a smartphone application,
and with it, you select
a blacklist of contacts.
And if those contacts
call or text you,
Cate will intercept
those calls and texts
and store it
within its interface.
So even if
your significant other
is looking directly
at your phone
when a blacklist contact
Calls or texts you,
she'll have no idea
it happened.
Let's just say
if tiger had Cate,
he might still
be married to Elin.
(laughter)
It's been estimated
that 80% of marriages
have at least
one cheating partner.
Shut up.
For real.
(laughs)
We like to say,
"Love is blind.
We keep it that way."
So, Neil, this is
a cheater's app?
But in reality,
it's a privacy app.
But let's call a spade a spade.
That's fine.
It's a cheater's app.
I'm okay with that.
(laughter)
Good for you, Neil.
Go with it, baby. Own it.
Neil...
for ex--Yes?
Why did you develop this?
You don't seem like
the cheater type of guy.
You are correct.
But I didn't actually
develop the app.
What I've done, pretty much
since I was 14,
I was a hustler.
I sold pokemon cards
on ebay.
I went to college,
did the 4-Year degree thing,
but I couldn't get a job
that I really wanted.
Went back to pokemon cards.
I found the app.
But you're not
a developer, right?
You didn't develop this?
No.
Tell us
the story there.
How did you find it?
What--What happened?
I found a guy
selling this app.
It turns out to be a cop.
He doesn't have time
for this app.
So a cop developed
a cheater's app?
Correct.
(laughs)
How much
did you pay the cop?
$17,500.
You paid him $17,500? Wow.
So you have 100%
ownership of this?
Between me and my sister,
yes. We're a team.
Is your app
totally developed already?
It's finished?
It's developed.
We--We just finished
the iphone version of it
a week or two ago,
so we have android,
iphone, and blackberry,
which covers 85% of
the cell phone market, and--
So, Neil,
how much are you
invested in it, all--Total?
We're...
to date?
Roughly around
$45,000, currently.
I don't know if cheating
is good or bad,
'cause I've never done it,
but I do understand
there are people that have,
and they need
a product like this.
Yeah.
So why don't you tell me
a little bit about your sales?
So far, we have around
10,000 customers, and...
You have 10,000
paid customers?
5,500, roughly,
paid customers,
and about 4,000
free customers.
Now--
How much did
the 5,500 who paid for it,
the actual cheaters,
what did they pay?
The app sells
for $4.99
for android and iphone,
and $9.99 for blackberry.
All right. So for--in three
months, you've sold how much?
It's about $5,000
to $5,500,
and $4,000 of that
is profit.
And today you think
that app, based on that,
is worth $1 million?
$1 million.
Yes!
I think you're cheating.
Neil, why are you offering us
such little percentage?
Do you really want a deal?
I do. And to be
perfectly honest,
I know the equity
is negotiable.
So I figure I should
come here with that,
and leave it
up to you guys.
But--But, Neil,
do you have any issues
or concerns about the morality
of the product you're promoting?
Let's put it this way--
What are you
talking about?
Let the guy answer a question.
It's okay. I'm okay. I-I'm okay
with you guys fighting.
I'm answering for you.
The answer is "No."
It's "no."
I'll just put it
in a better way.
Let's say you didn't like
carrots, for example.
Carrots?
Carrots.
But carrots sold
at 100% markup.
Are you gonna say,
"I don't wanna be
a carrot farmer,"
or are you going to
jump into that business,
ready to make money?
(laughs) In other words,
you're gonna go
where the money is,
is what you're saying.
Of course.
This is not "morality tank."
The only immoral aspect
of your deal
is the crazy valuation.
It's not worth
a million dollars.
That's for you guys
to decide.
That's what I think
it's worth.
Well, I think we're
telling you right now.
Look, I'm not gonna sit around
and listen anymore.
I understand the business.
I'll give you
the $50,000 for 50%.
I'd like to hear
the other offers.
Are there any other apps
that you could use this
programming code Base for
that you've considered?
What do you mean?
Let me give you one
right now.
In the mutual fund industry,
competitors don't like
their sales data
to be shown on a phone.
I'm gonna use this
in my business
on all
the sales reports.
That's exactly--
So I think there are apps
that will make sense there,
and this is one of them.
And they're--
It's really there,
if nothing else,
to prevent fights. If--
to prevent what?
Fights.
Like, a lot of--a lot
of girlfriends that I've known
have had boyfriends
who are overly jealous.
And they have guy friends,
and the boyfriend doesn't
want to see the guy friend
text message her.
So you get to keep
your friends
and keep
your boyfriend happy,
and everyone is happy.
And you might keep them alive.
See, you're saving
peoples' lives.
(Daymond) You're saving lives!
That's what I think I'm doing.
Yeah. I'm like
a firefighter.
(sharks laugh)
I like your passion,
I like the fact
that you're a hustler.
I don't like the app,
so I'm out.
There's a web site out there
that promotes cheating.
I know it.
The guy who runs it
and owns it
is a very close
personal friend of mine.
We summer together.
That's good.
I'm going right to him
after we form our partnership.
Now it's hard for me
to believe that you don't cheat.
I don't cheat.
(sharks laugh)
I'm kidding.
I don't cheat.
I believe in what
you believe in, okay?
I know the only thing
that matters in life is what?
Money. Yes.
Money. Of course.
You and me, we are in sync.
I'm gonna give you $50,000
right now for 50%. Let's go.
I have to hear
the rest of the offers.
Well, do we have
any other offers?
Neil, I'll make it--
I'll make it very simple.
I have a different philosophy.
I don't think
it's all about money.
I-I don't wanna be--
You're wrong.
I don't wanna be involved
in any business
where I can't
bring my kids to work.
I'm out.
Daymond, what are you doing?
I have to be very honest.
This is not my field.
So what I would like
to do,
if he would allow me--
and I would be partners
with Kevin
to make this a stronger deal,
if he allows me in.
All right. I'm interested
and I'm gonna agree.
(Robert) So Kevin and Daymond
are in at $50,000
for 50%.
You have a hard offer
on the table.
What are you going
to do?
You know, I happen to love,
uh, this concept.
Um, I happen to think
it has enormous application.
All right? My husband
was an FBI agent,
and used to have snitches
in white-collar crime
that would call him.
And the biggest problem was,
they didn't want
their name on his cell phone.
Oh, for sure.
If it wasn't narrowed
as a cheater's app
and it was a privacy app,
I think it has a tremendous
amount of application.
So I'd like
to make you an offer.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Neil has one offer
on the table
from Kevin and Daymond,
But Barbara
wants in on the action.
So I'd like to make you
an offer
for $50,000
for 30% of your business,
provided you're open
to repositioning it
as a privacy app
versus a cheater's app.
You know, this is one of
these situations
where you have to decide--
You can work
with a real estate Agent
who has no history
in software at all,
and I'm being nice
when I say that...
let me tell you
what I was successful in.
I was successful
in taking a $1,000 loan
and building it into
a $5 billion business.
So don't pull that card
on me, Kevin.
I am just--
I know that I don't know
as much as Barbara.
That's why I would have to
come in with Kevin,
because together,
collectively,
we can offer you
that muscle you need.
Counter them.
I'll offer you guys 15%.
Whoa.
Whoa. Hang on.
Whoa. Neil...
yes! You take it,
Neil.
You're countering
to all three of them...
yes.
15% for $50,000.
Correct.
We're not in the same
universe on this one.
(Barbara) Not me, no.
No, thank you.
It's all negotiation.
It's all up to negotiation.
It's a start-up act, Neil.
You're not--You're not
known anywhere yet.
You wanna bet?
If you want
a cheater's app,
if you want
big market exposure,
this is it.
All right. Let's stop
screwing around, okay, Neil?
You can do this whole thing
on your own, all right?
Yeah.
Or you can partner
with Daymond and I.
Yeah.
I'll drop this down
to 35% for 50k,
the two of us
are still in the deal?
I agree.
But it ain't gonna get
any cheaper.
You know what? That's gonna be
my last on this one,
because he's gonna start talking
his way out of this. So...
look, I think the two of us
bring So much value to you
that we have to get paid for it.
Neil, this is
your deal to lose.
Neil, you have
another offer on the table.
It's a better deal.
It's Only for 30%
for the $50,000.
You're telling me
for five points...
what are you gonna do?
You're not coming with me?
Are you out of your mind?
Do you want to call him
and look at that guy every day?
Neil, who do you see
more value in?
I'm sorry, Barbara,
I really do see value in him.
You know what I'll do?
I'll drop it down to 25%.
I'm not budging.
He's not budging.
There's--there's
a tremendous difference
in value here.
If you guys
would do $75,000
for 35%, we have
a deal right now.
You're just looking
at these guys?
You're not
entertaining this deal?
I have to see
if they'll take that,
because that would
equalize the equity.
But if they--
We'll do $60,000.
Done at $60,000.
We'll do it right now.
Done right now.
$60,000.
Stop it at $70,000,
and we got a deal.
We got a deal.
Done!
I love this guy!
(Daymond) Thank you.
I'm sorry, Barbara.
Thanks, guys.
(Mark) Congrats, Neil.
Bye.
All right.
Ooh, I love
a good deal. Mm!
Yeah, you guys can make
some money with it.
I love the kid.
Yeah, he's a great kid.
I was shocked that Kevin
had the perfect connection,
and bringing Daymond on board
just helped seal the deal.